welcome to this video playing alias oh
that's not very exciting the London
system I have zero out of two against
him that doesn't look good probably a I
don't know judging from this opening
maybe a games where I tried to do
something against this very boring set
up and in the process got into time
pressure and lost on time or something
there is a school of thought yeah I just
play completely unambitious opening and
move around as quickly as possible yeah
i'm preparing be five year v5 before for
the minority attack
yeah this is just like in the Queens
gambit declined in the the card spot
structure just with colors reversed yeah
it's interesting he pushed a 4 and a 5
here this Sun gives him a backward
backward sepan which is not necessarily
a big problem sometimes if white gets an
ID be 32 c 5 this is quite okay and you
might manage that in this position yeah
looks like looks like it so cancer some
some way to prevent that I don't really
think so it's not the end of the world
if he gets there but would be nice nice
to prevent and I wonder if Quincy for as
a move but he can go Bishop f5 night at
five and it's not leading to anything
Joe it was quite ok for wider all of
that
yeah it's hard to how to not take this
take this night he takes with the beep
on a half knight c6 and I can win the
pawn so he has to take with the Jeep on
I think wonder what he's thinking about
how can I wanted to play age 60 stupid
whenever I played this too quickly I
when I was thinking earlier okay night
g5 was interesting I have to play g6
then which I really don't want to play
yeah okay so nothing much happening here
maybe I can get in 'if I've at some
point that's a fairly solid position k
pawn takes you we'll grab a six so I
cannot do that can i play with if I
event and advance in the center might be
risky
might be slightly risky like f60 that I
didn't expect at all so he's saying that
d 4 is actually ok for him maybe
t-phone rupee 45 sure maybe maybe you
can do that yeah but still ok I have to
play that I mean ok I could have played
g6 off a mover and that that spirit but
yeah so i can i can take f4 right when
Luke takes this is actually quite ok and
if free at the end
f6 looks looks weird f5 is actually an
interesting move f5 rookie 5 rupee 5 fe5
Queenie form I came on that that's
interesting I don't know if it is good
but it's interesting if he takes I have
two connected passed pawns that are not
so easy to stop at all I'm quick with
King f7 and so on
it was interesting one danger is that
there's always those breakthroughs on
the queenside with b5 c6
Jim not so easy to play if I'm d6 and
III I mean yeah come on let's do that
you cannot take b7 I think it looks very
dangerous at least with d2d 24 21
handmade take be 70 how should I tell
how should he take b7 think about to
move that once when I take you five I
mean there are stuff like eat six
Queenie six okay with the king actually
I can take here for Quincy tune
in case of a kept charming
maybeee six
see if I was hey with a check so check
Jack difficult family so taking or I
guess sound taking it's got one check on
the edge yeah so let's just make a nice
little space on age seven so check
I thought the CIA should trade queens
check
white forfeits on time yeah maybe f5 was
good I don't know this is an interesting
interesting way to sharpen up this end
game let's have a look at at this
concrete situation here at four and then
f5 yeah I don't really know it is
interesting at least five so he has to
take and now this move the computer has
always completely fearless it wants to
take and play King f2 then rupee one
next check yeah that's stronger the king
is coming to e4 and I'm not I'm not
promoting with with any forceful play
yeah and white is better yeah okay that
was the refutation of my idea
interesting it was corrected was not
yeah he has to play king f2 first so
that he has this idea yeah I am and I
don't really have anything great yeah
he's also threatening to come up with
this so I shouldn't play Queenie for
what should I play I mean okay then I
don't play a five of course Queen a fawn
is some computer suggestion attacking
this pawn with equal player does this
probably make some sense i was thinking
it should be about equal so he has to
take and clicking after we went here
though again he can play can t gap
liking f2 didn't do that and now i can
take yes oh he was falling apart with
the clock ticking down oh okay yeah i
hope you enjoyed this interesting end
game at the end thanks for watching